what was it I said about Megan Mar I am
would you let me talk ever that's been
racist are you going to let me talk or
are you just going to overt talk me just
ask question stop asking
[Applause]
[Music]
question what about the issue of race
and I mentioned that in the context of
the Harry and Megan ongoing debate their
war with the royal family war against
the monarchy their specific uh constant
referencing to the fact that they
believe they were driven out of here
because of racism in Britain what do you
make of that debate that that's absolute
fallacy you're from a mixed race correct
background yourself correct I'm from a
mixed race background myself and while
we're discussing the leaders of the UK
although I do think they're doing a
terrible job it's kind of hard for Megan
to say that the UK is a racist country
when the leader of the UK is darker
skinned than her and the mayor of London
is darker skinned than her and I am a
person who's probably darker skinned
than her and I've never experienced any
kind of bigotry against myself besides
the fact I'm a straight male I'll get
bigotry for that before I'll get bigotry
for my skin color I think it's just a
cop out and her not wanting to be
perspicacious and self-reflective enough
to understand that she has attacked an
age-old institution and there are people
who are very patriotic about that
institution and by attacking it and
bringing a degree of distaste to it
there's G to be people who don't like
her and if you're a dislikable person
you can't just instantly stand up and
say it's because of my skin color it
might because be because of your actions
and some of the things you've said I
mean I think there's probably no doubt
she said racism on social media because
it's who hasn't it's aess you probably
have well as I said to I've had death
threats on social media and no one no
one seem to care very much um but I I
think that's probably inarguable my
issue with what they both been doing is
if you're going to make allegations
against an institution like the royal
family and the monarchy you've got to
actually provide some evidence you can't
just spray gun this thing out there and
say well somebody was racist yeah and
erroring dirty laundry is never going to
be respected by the populists and being
a tattle tale is never going to be
respected by the populist and I think
the problem with the modern world we're
living in is a lot of age-old traditions
are being destroyed in real time it
doesn't matter what the tradition is
most of them are being eroded and
something like the British royal family
which has been around for a very long
time is an age-old tradition one of the
things holding the UK together one of
the last things we have to sit and
detriment it and to sit and insult it
and to give away secrets from inside of
it and try and paint a negative image of
it is going to upset a lot of people and
you have to be prepared for that
backlash you can't say I've done things
to upset people but it's nothing to do
with what I've done it's purely because
of my skin color also it's kind of
ironic that she's doing that because
she's not particularly dark skinned it's
kind of funny to sit her sit here sit
watch her sit and say I think the truth
is I don't know what look you can say
that I can't um the reality of it is I
just don't know what the specifics of
the racism she says she's had because
we've not seen any evidence the universe
is a funny Place Pierce if you're
looking for something you're going to
find it right when I got cancelled when
they attacked me unfairly lied about me
across the entire mainstream media
deleted me from social media so I
couldn't defend myself and lied about me
repeatedly I could have stood up and
said it's because I'm Brown I didn't do
that I sat and said okay there's people
who misunderstand my message my message
is a is a positive one people
misunderstand me let me self-reflect and
understand that yes perhaps this said a
long time ago was said in the wrong way
perhaps this was misunderstood perhaps
people don't understand this I could
have just copped out and could have just
been refusing to self-reflect on any
level and said it's because I'm Brown
that's why they did it but that's not
the mature way to be as an adult I want
to turn to somebody else who who may
well have presid idential Ambitions and
has been the subject of a lot of
negativity uh mean marle Prince Harry's
wife who does this podcast uh archwell
podcast archetypes it's called in which
she seems to parentally play the victim
the female victim of all outrages and
your name got dragged into this uh let's
take a listen to to what she
said raise your hand if you've ever been
called crazy or hysterical
or what about nuts insane out of your
mind completely irrational I don't think
that men can control crazy women the use
of these labels has been drilled into us
from movies and TV from friends and
family and even from random strangers
and the fact is no one wants this
label what did you make of that Jordan
to be suddenly appearing on Mega
markle's podcast as a villain the first
thing holding women crazy is that she
yeah well the first thing I make of it
is that her voice drips with the same
falsehood that the voice of camela
Harris drips with it's this
sanctimonious um faux compassionate
talking down to her audience and trying
to be sure that we're all really on the
same compassionate page here and we're
all being victimized by terrible forces
that are arrayed against us none of
that's really fair and it's it just
grats on me and I do believe uh you you
played a bit of a clip from me when I
was talking to um um uh Pia c c uh
Camille pelia uh the literary critic and
I do believe that it is the case that
it's very difficult to control female
antisocial Behavior often of the type
that's been pillared as hysterical and I
think that there's no shortage of
clinical evidence to support precisely
that um claim it's very difficult for
women to control female antisocial
behavior and females who are antisocial
that feminine pattern is reputation
savaging under the guise of
Compassionate Care and it's it's
extraordinarily destructive and
uh so I stand by my words absolutely and
I do think it scales online because you
can use an anonymous reputation savaging
to unbelievably great effect online with
absolutely no punishment for your sins
so to speak and that is certainly one of
the things that's contributing to
so-called cancel culture and there's no
shortage of that coming from the female
side now men can engage in exactly the
same strategies and they do so online
and that's enabled but um it's
definitely see with men and I've said
this before and I do believe this to be
the case the the everpresent threat of
the potential for physical violence
keeps men from doing that to each other
most of the time in person and that all
disappears on line and that means that
those who are prone to do such things to
use corrosive and denigration
denigrating derision for example and
reputation savaging can have a free hand
at it and that includes no shortage of
women and women are often very very
often the targets of that behavior from
their own from their own fellows so to
speak ER thank you very much inde for
joining me and now I don't know much
about you other than you wrote a piece
last week for Rolling Stone magazine
saying cancel culture is good for
democracy so I'm going to come to that
ludicrous premise in a minute uh but I
also remember you Tweeting when I uh
left Good Morning Britain a series of
tweets calling me a racist including
enjoying how folks keep getting Piers
Morgan together for his racist tyes
against Megan Markle on Good Morning
Britain I was just curious could you
could you remember a single racist thing
that I said about her or have ever said
about
it well thank you for having me on
Pierce I was surprised when I found out
I would be on your show an uncensored
show we take we take all types on
it I I well all types well there you go
um but I I think really a lot of it just
seemed to be biased I think that you was
really just harsh on on you know the
Dutchess of susex and I think there was
a little bit of bias in the way that you
had really gone after her yeah but ER to
be clear I didn't ask you about that I
just say what were the racist tyes what
what racist thing have I ever said about
Mega Marco I'm curious you you he
tweeted quite a few times that I was a
racist I'm just curious what was the
racism I said I said your remarks I said
your remarks was racist I didn't what
were the remarks racist racist I think
that it's biased I think that you had a
a sense of bias of how you were speaking
about her and how you was really being
insensitive to her mental health a lot
of her concern being biased or skeptical
of some of her claims is not the same as
being racist what was the thing I said
that was racist I never hold on do you
want the person of color to speak or do
you want to just talk over me nothing to
do with your skin colorest sorry nothing
to do with your skin color I don't care
if you're black or white or okay well
anything else I just want you to try and
tell me giv you tweeted to your many
followers repeated by way repeatedly you
did this repeatedly you have called me a
racist repeatedly for racist things I've
said about Mega Mar simp want you to to
stand by what you tweeted what was it I
said about Mega Mar I am would you let
me talk ever that's been racist you have
recently chosen lately in your career
for whatever reason you have went the
road of basically baiting into a lot of
the bias coverage of Megan Marco and a
lot of it has a lot of it has been
targeted towards her in a biased way and
and come on can you admit that the
coverage around Megan marle has been
racially biased can you admit that
absolutely not talking about your work
but in general I think it's another load
of absolute hogwash nonsense so you're
dismissing the rle of race in all of
this you don't think none of this has a
role say The British media the British
media has never been racist about Megan
marle okay that's just a lie and we're
going to agree or disagree age disagree
it's a fact no it's not what is a lie
what is a lie Hest is you telling people
repeatedly I'm a racist and then you
can't produce any evidence other than
it's your feeling you made a racist High
rate and you're and you're and you're
offended but but here's the thing you're
blaming me for the criticism I'm not
offend you said you're blaming me as a
high influential black person and by the
way you're blaming me for your criticism
has nothing to do with your skin
colonist I don't
care black influential person you named
my race you said you're a black
influential person and that's why people
thought that way so why did you bring my
race into it I think when high-profile
black people like you go public on
Twitter okay high profile black people
like me go public on Twitter and call me
a racist people like you went public on
Megan Mar believe people believe it and
you know what it's a it's a and people
believe what you said about Megan Marco
or no it's a lie I watched you yesterday
and the day before I watched you be gas
lit by two ignorance black women and I
actually felt quite sorry for you so I
want to say welcome to the club Piers
Morgan how does it feel to be gas lit
when claiming something is racism how's
it feel it's annoying right it's
annoying well Trisha here's your chance
to respond this was of course about our
quite fiery debate in which I got very
exercised about the fact that Megan and
Harry for two years led the world to
believe that the palace had been racist
about the skin color of their baby and
then they decided to turn around and say
actually we never meant that at all
which I thought was deplorable you
defended it and that was iman's verdict
on your defense I was basically getting
gas lit what's your
response um not so much the gas lit bit
but um I guess Iman and I would have to
um agree to dis agree I wouldn't call
anybody ignorant just because they don't
agree with my point of view um and I
don't think it's helpful especially when
we're discussing something like racism
um you know one black person calling
another person black ignorant because
they don't agree that so that that I
find that I find sad I I'm saddened by
that and and you know so I'm not going
to pick a fight with IM man about that
because I've seen that happen uh on you
know I've worked in the media for 35
years I know how that game's played um
so so that would be my only comment
she's entitled to her view um you're
entitled to your view I'm entitled to my
view but I think it's I actually think
it's quite disgraceful to label someone
ignorant purely because they don't agree
with you we have it's not acceptable to
call someone ignorant but you can call
them disgraceful
Imam well uh no no I said doing it is
disgraceful the same thing you just
called it disgraceful IM you're
for calling
ignorant I think it's we just heard you
you just said she was disgraceful so let
her answer the Char of being she was
disgraceful okay Iman you're a disgrace
for calling Trisha ignorant I think I'm
awesome personally so I just want to
throw that out there secondly I never
called you uh ignorant because you
didn't agree with my opinion I called
you ignorant because you have a lack of
knowledge there's a clear difference and
it was never about a view it's about
just understanding facts and when we
talk about unconscious bias that's based
on feeling that is a fact fact Trisha so
it's not about me and you disagreeing as
two black women I'm going to call you
ignorant in spite of your color if you
have a lack of knowledge simple as that
oh thank you so much you're welcome well
Trisha come on you got to answer the
charge it was basically your ignorance
as in as in lack of knowledge of the
subject you were talking about if
somebody decides that I'm ignorant I'm
not going to sit here and try to to
dissuade them otherwise they've quite
clearly made up their minds if mom wants
to call me ignorant and thinks of me and
ignorant what have
you fine go ahead you did a lot of
damage that day you did a lot of damage
and I had to come along and fix it just
like Harry did a lot of damage and other
people had to come along and fix it me
scha kande we had to come along and fix
your dirty works you know what I don't
have time for people like you when you
come on national TV spewing garbage and
you're right I'll actually add to your
second point I don't want to argue
because I'm a bit more in fact I don't
believe black women should come on to TV
arguing so I'll just leave it at that I
called you ignorant because of your lack
of of knowledge it kind of ends there
basically I mean Trisha what I would say
as the token white man in this debate is
I would say this about what happened
last week I was surprised actually that
you with all your experience of
broadcasting and journalism you're
you're a smart person that even you when
you heard Harry basically gaslighting
the World by saying we never it was the
media that said that this was racism we
didn't say that and then you lit Ally
watch back exactly what they said to
Oprah Winfrey and they were blatantly
accusing a senior member of the royal
family of being racist about their
unborn child skin color I was surprised
that you couldn't find it in yourself
not withstanding your support for them
but as a black woman to understand the
damage that that did in playing the race
card as strong as it did to Oprah
Winfrey and then expecting two years
later we would all just sit back when
they go we didn't mean it as racism and
we still go oh oh that's all right then
after two years I want to talk about two
uh sets of people who are globally known
and I've had a lot said and written
about them the first uh on the lighter
end uh Harry and Megan the dukee and
Duchess of Sussex you have some quite
strong views about these favor yeah tell
me tell me about your views of these two
I love them they're my they're my
favorites you know reality television in
America had kind of died down and
they've brought it back um it's very
interesting to make a three-part
documentary on Netflix about how bad
things are while living in a castle I
find that the lack of self-awareness
there to be very fun I mean they're very
funny I they simulated some type of car
chase in New York City that didn't
really happen uh there was a cab driver
that there was driving them around said
it did not happen um they've you know I
know people in Los Angeles that they've
texted and reached out to because they
kind of want to hang out in these
circles with celebrities they got a big
deal at Spotify Spotify didn't make any
money now the articles are coming out
that Spotify lost a lot of money giving
them money to do all these things that
they never ended up really doing and
nobody ended up listening after the
first few episodes um so victimhood it
makes me laugh and when someone is
clearly not a victim and I think living
in a castle being part of a royal family
um would make you not a victim and to me
to P portray yourself as somebody who's
having a rough go of it whilst living in
a castle with royal protection and then
leaving and flying to America to stay in
the home of a big celebrity and it's a
beautiful home uh they make me laugh I
mean I I like them I hope they don't go
away I hope they keep doing this I hope
they keep behaving shamefully it's great
for the tabloids it's great for us we
keep doing it keep simulating car chases
simulate terrorist attacks whatever they
want to do that keeps them in the news
I'm all for it Harry and Megan the
currently the Juke and Duchess of six
famously gushed about their love of
chickens in one of the more sacarin
moments of their Oprah Winfrey so Fest
well the chickens are now coming home to
roost for these two the royal family
kept a stoic silence as the poison darts
rained down from their Californian
pedestal but King Charles is quietly and
devastatingly taking charge now we now
know that he booted the couple out of
their palacial Frogmore Cottage just 24
hours after Harry's book spare or spare
me as I call it was published we also
now know that Harry and Mega's
popularity is crated on both sides of
the Atlantic with polls showing even
prince Andrew is now more popular than
they are in America as well as now being
offered the keys to their house and we
also now know that in America where
they' strained every senu to become much
l celebrities that're actually viewed
like this so let me start with you sir
you've lived a life with the royal
family you've had everything handed to
you but you say your life has been hard
and now you've written all about it in
your new book when
yes that's right friend you see my wife
and I are totally like you should write
a book cuz your family like stupid and
then s like
journalists there's now a clear divide
in the roal family the workers and the
shers the heavy lifters and the grifters
The Prince and Princess of Wales luded
Welsh guards yesterday at in David Day
Parade Camila the queen conso recovering
from a recent B of covid with promoting
children's literature King Charles is
preparing to make State visits to
Germany and France in his first Royal
tourist was monar mean Marco meanwhile
made a state visit to a coffee shop
which sells superfood lates inspired by
holistic ingredients from around the
world and Prince Harry had another
routing on us late night television The
Leftovers of a previous interview taped
on his pity
tour Harry what is the best
sandwich I would say a chees andham
toasty with Dijon mustard on top
and a toasty means grilled is that that
means okay there you go unbelievable
that guy's sixth in line of the throne
on Saturday he's out of the game
flogging tickets to a digital seminar of
family trauma his trauma from his $13
million California
Mansion uh you have to pay $33 by the
way to tune in online to see him banging
on about his trauma again and what a
victim he is and how it's all so beastly
and unfair that he's making hundreds of
Millions fleecing his Royal titles
without doing any Royal Duty for it but
that's his level Now isn't it for Harry
a gossiping gutter snipe selling out his
family to the highest biders a wannabe
reality star but that star is fading
fast Harry and Megan think they can
carry on having their Royal cake and
eating it using those Royal titles I
could say while abusing the institution
that afforded them those titles and as
usual I'm afraid they're wrong and King
Charles is right to draw the curtain on
Miss lud soap opera on May the 6th the
King has his coronation it will be one
of the most important moments in modern
British history and the very last thing
we need or want are the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex current titles rocking up with
their camera Crews to distract attention
and get more material for their next Act
of money grabbing betrayal next week
2,000 invitations will be sent out in my
view it's time for Charles to be firm
and make sure they're not on that list
join
[Applause]
n